the Wright brothers didn't invent flight
there were men before them like otto
lilienthal that made their own
revolutionary contributions to the
development of flight his book bird
flight as the basis of aviation was
beautifully illustrated with over 23
years of experiments and observations of
bird flight this book set the stage for
his own flying machines and inspired the
Wright brothers to create their own Otto
had figured out how to achieve lift but
he had no stable way of controlling his
gliders if a wind struck the glider he
would shift his center of gravity by
trying his legs in the direction the
wind came from this would correct the
flight provided he hadn't tipped too far
already in 1896 a powerful wind hit his
glider and he was unable to recover the
crash resulted in his untimely death
this affected the Wright brothers deeply
and inspired them to continue Otto's
life work they improved on Otto's
experimental lift data allowing their
planes to achieve more lift and they
created a custom lightweight engine to
power their plane but their biggest
contribution was creating a stable plane
with full control to have full control
of an aircraft you need to have control
of rotation around the three principal
XY and z axis rotation around the x axis
is called roll and the Wright brothers
invented an ingenious wing warping
mechanism to controllers using a system
of pulleys and wires the pilot could
bend the wings so one side angled
downwards while the opposite side angled
upwards causing an increase in lift on
the upward facing side and a decrease in
lift on the downward facing side those
causing a turning moment around the x
axis rotation around the z axis is
called pitch and it controls the
elevation the pilot could control the
elevator with a library to increase or
decrease the angle of attack this would
increase or decrease the lift and again
cause a turning moment around the z axis
the final rotation is called yaw and it
is controlled by the rudder which works
similarly to the elevator and controls
the rotation around the y axis with
these innovations the Wright brothers
created a plane that wasn't just a
novelty toy it had practical
applications and without break of World
War one just around the corner these
applications would soon be exploited and
developed quickly today planes come in a
variety of shapes and sizes but the
primary principles of control developed
by the Wright brothers remain the same
the Wright brothers didn't invent flight
they perfected it if you'd like to learn
more about the Wright brothers and the
Wright Flyer you can visit my web site
here for my next video I will be
discussing
the development of supersonic flight and
white wings I sometimes angled backwards